Lucan ate here with the octo Boys
YouTube channel and we're gonna do some
foraging it's fall and that means it's
time to pick autumn olives yeah now
every year we do a video about
harvesting and processing autumn olives
and every year I try to do something
slightly different this year I'm gonna
try making autumn all of soda pop autumn
olive butter and a few other things are
you excited
this bush right here the Nathans eating
berries off of that's an autumn olive
it's an invasive plant here in the East
Coast it grows
lots of places where there's full Sun
usually the edge of roads bike trails
the edge of meadows or streams got these
very distinct berries they're red with
yellow dots on them and you can see here
they get up to about 12 feet tall but
most of the bushes are more like eight
feet tall six feet tall this bush is
also really distinct in that the berries
grow in really thick clusters which
makes it easy to harvest a lot of fruit
the autumn olive leaves are these long
skinny smooth leaves they go from dark
green to almost a bluish color another
thing that makes it very distinct is it
has this very large single pit in the
center of the fruit the autumn olive
tastes a little bit like a linden berry
or a cranberry but if you get it right
at maximum ripeness they are sweet mmm
these ones are good here in Virginia the
berries start to ripen into September
when the nights start to get cold and
you know the berries are ripe when you
jiggle them even just a little bit and
you start to get berries falling off the
best way to harvest autumn olives is to
get a big basket or a widemouth bin hold
it under the tree and just sit here and
loosen the berries just rub them between
your fingers and knock them off all
right all these berries are just from
two bushes and about ten minutes of
picking so you can see you can get a lot
of berries very quickly with these
autumn olives they just produce a ton of
fruit one weird thing about autumn
olives is that they only tend to produce
large amounts of fruit every other year
last year this bush was insanely full of
berries now this year you're lucky if
you can find twelve along bike paths and
roads are great places to look for
autumn olive oh here's one rather nice
and ripe that's good the more the
merrier the more the Berrier
[Applause]
[Music]
well I ended up filling up the 5-gallon
bucket a little over one and a half
times so that's about 8 gallons of
berries that it took me about two and a
half hours all right we want to separate
the good berries for all the leaves and
stems and bugs and rotten fruit put a
cooler or a tub or something like this
you put it on a slant
[Music]
there you go working just get in there
and agitate it very gently to free up
all the trapped stems and leaves it
didn't close through the surface
all right we're just gonna let that run
for a little bit
five minutes in the cooler and it looks
really clean it doesn't need to be
perfect there's still a few stems here
and there because when we remove the
pits we'll also get rid of the stems and
any leftover debris this will generally
want to clean and you don't want a ton
of debris
got a very little bit of water on the
bottom of this pot alright after only a
few minutes of boiling the berries are
turning to this soup and we can let that
cool and then separate the pits and
stems out from the juice just one so
when you run the auto balls through a
food mill you get the juice and you get
the pulp you let it sit and you get
separation like this so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to pour off just the
juice or as much of the juice as I can
and use it in some autumn olive soda pop
and the pulp I'm going to try to make oh
maybe some fruit leather out of that
might add it to the apple butter
we're gonna kind of play it by ear see
what happens
[Music]
[Applause]
so I've separated the pulp into a pan
here we're gonna reduce this and make it
into a thick jelly all right guys I'm
gonna go ahead and add some malt sugar
syrup to this autumn olive jelly I
prepared this about a week ago and let
me show you how I made it
so the first step to making mulch is I'm
gonna soak the barley sprouts just soak
them in the water for anywhere from an
hour to overnight and dump these sprouts
right in there so there we go got a half
inch layer of barley seeds sandwiched
between wet paper towels it's been one
week and you can see the barley is
sprouted really good it looks like a
beautiful lawn so we're gonna go and pry
this out of the basket here you can see
it's got some roots in the bottom so
we're gonna have to really pry this here
we go oh that smells wonderful but now
I've got all this paper towel I need to
pick out so maybe I shouldn't have done
that
alright eight cups of uncooked rice here
I'm gonna rinse it wash it and add a
little bit more water than I normally
would so slightly more than one to one
and that's going to make a really soupy
wet sticky rice that maxed out my rice
cooker alright let's check the rice out
ooh that looks good
[Music]
oh yeah that there you go that's the way
it should all right look at that nice
and separating starting to turn brown
we'll put it back in the oven for
another six hours or so and that will do
well all right there we go almost two
gallons of malt syrup I'm gonna go to
bed and tomorrow morning we're gonna
start reducing this and we're gonna make
sugar and syrup out of this once it
starts to boil you get this kind of
brown foam on the top just skim it off
at the spoon and keep boiling it well
there you go I reduced the malt syrup by
half and it's about the consistency of
hot syrup right now it'll get a little
thicker once it cools down but it tastes
really good it's sweet and has this malt
flavor a really strong malt flavor with
it
it's it's different than anything else
you've tasted it's a really unique
flavor all right the malt syrup is done
look how dark golden brown that is
you
so me neither to Jacob we're gonna do a
little apple picking you guys excited
look at this wood well we're here at
Heartland orchards in Northern Virginia
and we're we picking our own apples they
have a lot of different types of apples
here but it seems like here in the
middle of September Fuji's and mousses
are the most common one
we're gonna pick mostly Fugees because I
want to make cider out of those I think
those will make the best cider
it's tough go put those in the bag for
me okay guys that's one bag all right we
got four bags one bushel of Fuji one
bushel of musu that's a lot of apples
[Applause]
it's big your own children
all right we have two bags or one bushel
of Fuji apples here we're gonna use this
thing take the core out then we're gonna
smash them up we're gonna put them in
the cider press and make some cider okay
you guys ready to smash some apples
[Music]
overblowing
all right so yeah
that is amazing look at that beautiful
stuff oh sweet Mother of mercy that's
the best I ever tasted
I'm going to take the leftover pressed
apple chunks and I'm going to boil them
and we're going to turn that into apple
butter here you can add some water to
this and then boil the crap out of it
[Music]
add some cinnamon I've boiled this down
about 75% and you can see it's nice and
thick and smooth the peels are mostly
gone looking good we're getting close
[Music]
all right so the autumn model of syrup
is all done nice and thick they're the
apple butter is smooth and thick and all
done there and we've got four loaves of
fresh bread to the boot I'm gonna make
two batches one is just straight apple
butter and the other is autumn all of
apple butter now we're gonna take some
of this autumn olive syrup we're gonna
mix those together so we mixed about two
parts autumn all up to one part apple
butter and it makes a really nice combo
the apples butter makes it smooth the
autumn olive makes it strong flavor do a
little bit tart it's nice really nice
all right let's check out this autumn
all of apple butter here oh yeah I like
it it's not a strong player it's not as
strong flavored as Jam or something it's
it's more subtle you know I know there's
not as much sugar in it as Jam all in
all it took about 20 hours of boiling to
make the apple butter so that was really
time consuming that to the long time to
boil that
[Music]
all right all right let's get the fruit
leather out all right there we go there
we go there's a beautiful piece of fruit
leather look at that
anything you want to try some of this no
[Music]
all right gluten huh
takes a lot of berries to make fruit
leathers that one little bit was
probably a big of berries like this
[Music]
making autumn olives cider or soda is
pretty simple take the juice with this
little pulp as you can get add white
sugar and malt sugar until you get the
flavor you want and then that's it
that's all you need if it's a little too
strong dilute it with some water if it's
too thin boil it down and reduce it once
it's cold then we'll go and bottle it
try the flavor of it see if you like the
flavor we're just adding about 7 to 10
grains of yeast to each bottle
[Music]
all right got a dozen soda bottles out
here in this beautiful fall weather it's
about room temperature outside and that
yeast will eat up the sugar and it'll
give off carbon dioxide it'll cause
pressure to increase in the tops of the
bottles and that will carbonate the soda
pop we'll leave it out here for about
two days and then after that we
refrigerate it to shut the yeast off to
keep it from going I'll come back and
check on this in two days oh come here
trap well there we go autumn all of the
soda pop I might have over carbonated
that a little bit the biggest downside
to using yeast to carbonate is that you
have to refrigerate it after it's done
fermenting otherwise it'll turn
alcoholic on you but it's kind of a fun
little thing and as you can see it
definitely gets plenty fizzy man look at
that look at the head on that one nice
thing about using these flip-top bottles
is that when the pressure gets a little
bit too much it just leaks out the side
of the seal instead of blowing the top
off the bottle but so that makes it a
little bit safer a little bit of an
update here I was talking to some
friends about my autumn olive sodas and
they asked me are they alcoholic I
assume the answer is no because it's not
really that much fermentation but I
figured I would find out turns out I'm a
little bit of a legal nerd I'm a defense
attorney and I collect breathalyzer
machines
I'm multifaceted so I brought one of my
breathalyzers here this is the CM is d2
and this is the preliminary breath
testing device used by the local police
department here I'm expecting a little
bit of a reading I get a point zero
three a point zero two off of just
eating white bread if this was hard
liquor like whiskey I would probably get
0.7 or 0.8
by blowing into this machine just after
drinking us up so that'll give us kind
of a range or comparison look at the
bubbling action on this so much
carbonation
[Applause]
alright so it's peaking on a point oh
four four so this has just slightly more
alcohol in it than a slice of white
bread so based on the breathalyzer
results and some rough calculations this
homemade soda has about as much alcohol
as a non-alcoholic beer like an O'Doul's
slightly more than a slice of white
bread and about as much maybe a little
bit more than eating a honey bun we had
two bushels of apples in about 40 pounds
of autumn olive berries and from that we
got five gallons of apple cider 36
bottles of autumn olive soda
three litres of malts two pounds of
fruit leather about 30 jars of apple
autumn olive butter thanks for watching
we hope you enjoyed these videos don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning take care
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
belt like you'll get
thanks for watching